♪♪
T STEADILYHETO DONATTEMPT TO HIT
CRIMINAL AND CNN'S SARRAY HAS N?
H BUT DOESN'AN IGEAR.SINCE OTOFH
SHE HASN'T BEEN WORKING QUIETLY
CASEGAORMER PRESIDTRUMP.
>> ALL OF A SUDDEN WE HA ARIGGEN
STATE FOR A RALLK AND
CONTINUES TO ERE HIS BS
ELECTION GRIEVANS.HE TRUMP INVEN
>> ReporULTOCOUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY QUIETLY
EA HER
2020 ELECTIORESUFORTS N GEORGIA'
HER TEAM HAS BEEN COUCTING
COECAND D A LI OF ES
COMMITTEES INVESTIGATING THENUA
>> INTVIHINGS ARE
BEING RE.
>> AS ST ATTORNEY, INOT HAVE TH
HAVE HNEY ON ANY CRIME
.
RAFFENSPERGER THAT SET WILLIS'S
>> ALL I WANT TO DO S, I W11,7
MORE THAN WE HAVE
BECAUSE WE WONTATE.>> Reporter:
Y
INVESTIGATORS HAVE ALREA D ND RS
, INCLUDING GAING GABR
>> THERE'S NO SHREDDING OF
GOING ON.
IT'SOT RL.
ILR E A ATION EM
CONGRESSIONAL STIGATORS.E  C
REQUESTEREUNICATION BEN
WHITE HOUSE ANALS ASL COMMUNICA
ORBIT,E
OF STAFF, MARK MWS
GIULIANI. IT IS CERTAINLY INFOR
>> A SOUMILIARH SAYS THERE'S B
STAFF LEL N
WI OFFICNGRESSIONAES, THOUGH
ANR SOURCES
NO ACTIVE INFORMATIOSHFAR.
FOR WILLIS, THE TRUMP
INVESTIGATION IS A JUGGLING AC
PRESSURE.
IF YOU JUST REMEMBER, SHE'
ELECD
COUNTY.E TRUMSTIGATION
MAY GET MORE PRETI
BASIS, SHE CLEARLY HAS TO
VOTERWHR.HE FACES RISING
VIOLENCE IN THE ATLANT
BKL CASES A
PANDEMID
PREDECESSOR.
>> WE'RE DEALING WITH 11,000
CASE BACKLOG.
SOUR MOST OUS AND
>> RepteDING
LOCAL OFFICIALS FORS AND WNING.
I NEED HteE.
NE PRIY IS TO
E te SURAT WE KEEP VIOLENT
HER INN
>> WE'RE GOING TUNTIL IT'S
THANK YOU.
>> Reporter: TCRETARY OF STA'S C
DUIN
ESSENT E IALTHER U THE CALLS
IS ON GOING. OUT
TRUMP'S TEAM FOR COMMENT THEY
DIDN'T G B
>> DYO'S
ABOUT ?
T  DE E D.A. IN GEORGIA HAS NONN
>> WOWNTUEO
THANK YOU FOR THE REPORT.
PE UTA, THNGWAVES.TSS CHAIRMANL
NUCHECKERUMP DIDN'T START
WITH M FRE
HE
AND THE SECR HISTORY ONUCLEAR BR
PROCESS,RE SPECIFICALLY AND
THIS IS SOMETHING YOE .WHATCT T
OT THEK
THE CLES ABOUT IT, WHAT DIO TOEO
THAT NUCLEARSS?
>> THERE'S BEEN HYPE AHIS
BOTH IN THE BONDGET  QUICKLY HO.
THE PRESIDDOESN'T HAVE A
PMEN WITH AIG
BRIEFCASE D HAS COMMUNICATIONS
ND COD
HE MESSAGE TO SOMETHINCAL MILITY
COMMANNTER IN THE PENTAGON
E STAR
HAT, YES
ME.
HO MAKES F T T
THHOS OL E A FEW OFFICIALS ARN ,
ON-MAKINTHEY'RE IN ON THPROCESS.
STAND IT, AL
E  THENDENTER E
INN THIS
T MAKE SURON THETO SUBVER
>> YH.WHICH IS PART OF PROCEDURO
>> YEAH. >>HA T
TO
ING WITH THEGISO CALL.SECRETARY
WHICH, YOU KNOW,
S REALLYOOD IDEA'S DON JOEN OR
CORDIN T DOESN'T DON'T FOLOES N
OTHER PEOPLE HERE.
A MESSAGE TO T STAFF
GET ANY UNUSUALORDERS FROE HOU
EVERYWHEIN DNO UNTIL YOU COM.T
Y FFERENT.
LARGER ISSUE.
PEOPLE KNOW THIS IDENT UY
EAR WAR.
WHAT IS BEING DONE TO AD?
TH AGE ON THIS SUBJECT
OF NUC L
INTE AND
DONALD TRUMP
UNSTABLESIDENTS
WHAT CAN W ABOUT T
AND ID NOTHI
ABOUT THIS.
>> AGA, IT'S NOT IN TH